My husband got back from a work trip last night
and he mentioned that he had this really good chocolate
peanut butter cup ice cream,
so I decided to make him some today.
I started by making my peanut butter cups.
To do that, I started with the filling by making some Graham crackers.
I combined butter and sugar with some flour, cinnamon,
some milk, and honey.
Let that all come together
and then refrigerated my dough
while I got started on making some peanut butter.
I blended up my roasted peanuts until it reached the consistency
I wanted, set that aside, and then got started on my ice cream base.
Mix some heavy cream with some dark cocoa and added some chocolate.
While that all heated up on the stove,
I separated my egg whites from my yolks
and then poured in some of my warm milk.
I let that come up to temperature
and then transferred it back over to my milk,
let it thicken up until it coated the back of my spoon
before combining that with my chocolate and heavy cream
and putting that in the fridge.
At this point I pulled out my dough,
rolled it out, and poked some holes in it.
Let that bake until crispy,
and I made sure to let them cool fully
before breaking them up and adding them to my blender
and pulsing them until they turned into crumbs.
Combine them with some powdered sugar
and then added in My peanut butter
and giving that a really good mix
before lining my muffin tin with some liners,
brushing those with melted chocolate before refrigerating them,
and then once they'd set,
scoop to my peanut butter filling and with more chocolate.
All those were setting in the fridge.
I poured my ice cream mixture into my Turner and let that turn.
I pulled pulled out my peanut butter cups,
chopped them up, and added them to my ice cream.
Once it reached soft serve consistency,
I transferred my mixture over to my dish
before putting some more chopped up peanut butter cups on top.
Set that in the freezer for a few hours,
and lucky said it was the best ice cream he's had in a while.